out to prepare for pregnancy. That's a broad question because I don't know are you already
pregnant? If you're already pregnant, then you just want to make sure you're getting your
proper nutrition. If you're not pregnant, if you're having difficulty getting pregnant or
holding the pregnancy, that's a whole other picture that you want to look at getting a Dutch test
looking at your hormones would be the right thing to do. Quite often, estrogen dominance, a progesterone
deficiency, but we'd want to look at the picture there. If you're just trying to say, hey, I'm
ready to start having babies and I want to be as healthy as possible, well, that's the same thing
as if you're trying to be as healthy as possible for anything. So, getting some lab work done,
seeing what's going on, seeing what I need to do to help balance my gut to prevent.
If I could go into the pregnancy as healthy as possible, then I'm going to have less problem. So
that's the whole key. So try to do everything you can to be as healthy as possible and the thing is
is to get a good workout. So get a good blood work up. See where you're at. That would be the thing
that I would recommend.